estas imágenes Fueron publicadas por los
guardacostas suecos el jueves muestran
una cuarta Fuga que emana de los
gasoductos nordstream a principios de
esta semana se informó de otros tres
escapes la otan se sumó el jueves al
coro de los que dicen que toda la
información apunta a una acción
coordinada toda la información
actualmente disponible indica que esto
es el resultado de actos de Sabotaje
deliberados imprudentes e irresponsables
cualquier ataque deliberado contra la
infraestructura crítica de los aliados
se enfrentaría con una respuesta unida y
decidida las estaciones sísmicas de toda
la región dijeron que habían registrado
explosiones submarinas en las zonas
antes de las fugas Suecia ha aumentado
los niveles de alerta en dos de sus tres
centrales nucleares y este jueves el
ministro de defensa danés llegó a la
isla de born cerca de donde se
encontraron las otras dos fugas Allí se
reunió con la tripulación del f-16 que
ha estado inspeccionando las fugas de
gas desde el aire y en Finlandia que
también limita con el mar Báltico
actividades han dicho que estaban
vigilando de cerca sus aguas y que
reforzarían las medidas de seguridad en
infraestructuras críticas como el
gasoducto baltic conector pero los
incidentes también han suscitado
preocupación por la seguridad de las
infraestructuras energéticas en otros
lugares de Europa
Este es el único acontecimiento bueno de
este mal suceso el gas no ha llegado a
Alemania ni a Europa a través de ninguno
de los dos gasoductos esto significa que
este acontecimiento no ha tenido ninguna
repercusión en la situación del
suministro pero ahora por supuesto hay
que tomar precauciones Definitivamente
hay gasoductos que son importantes para
nosotros hay plantas de gas licuado una
infraestructura energética de gas y
tiene que estar Bien protegida y estoy a
favor de pagar el precio de la seguridad
ahora y no cuando sea demasiado tarde
todavía no está claro quién podría estar
detrás de cualquier ataque deliberado
contra los gasoductos y hasta que no se
descargue todo el gas es demasiado
peligroso que los equipos técnicos
inspección en las estructuras